Billy, Robert,
congratulations.
You've made it to the final
round of this competition.
Now, we're sending you
back to your home forges
to recreate an iconic weapon
that helped win World War II--
the Scottish backsword.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
[heavy metal music]
So it's day one, and
I'm going to get started
on my Scottish backsword.
So right now, I'm
just cleaning off
my steel, just to make sure that
I get a good, clean forge weld.
I don't have the steel
that's a proper thickness,
so I'm going to be forge welding
three pieces of 1080 steel
together.
I'm doing it all by
hand, so it's going
to take a little bit longer.
[heavy metal music]
So I'm making a
Scottish backsword.
I'm going to try to
make it as historically
accurate as I possibly can.
Let's make it hot.
Day one is making
the Damascus, forging
the blade, and then quench.
Woo, boy!
There's a risk that the
Damascus will blow apart.
And if it messes up, I won't
have time to start again.
Forge welding Damascus
is always a risky thing,
but it will make the blade
far more aesthetically
pleasing, which
will hopefully give
me a boost in this competition.
Things are OK.
I've got my blade
forged to shape.
I'm ready to go in the quench.
I can't believe I got
this much done in one day.
I think that might have
been a successful quenching.
Coming out.
Aha!
So today, I have a
little bit of grinding
left to establish my bevels.
And then the plan after
that is heat treat.
Once I come right
out of the quench,
I lay the sword down here,
clamp everything down tight.
And hopefully, if
there is any warp,
it straightens it out
as the blade is cooling.
If things go wrong here, I could
possibly have to start over.
I have to nail it and get
it right the first time.
All right.
Here we go.
I saw some good color when
it came out of the quench.
The blade looked
fairly straight.
I didn't hear any thinks or
cracks or anything happen,
so I think we're good.
My plan for today is
to make the basket hilt.
It's easily the toughest
part of this build.
I'm going to try my
best to make this thing
out of a single piece of steel.
That's why you drill it slow.
I'm going to try to
put my own spin on it.
I want to put the American flag
and the shape of the Purple
Heart medal to honor
the men and women who
have given all to our country.
At least as much work
is going into the handle
as is going into the blade.
It can be a Scottish backsword
with an American touch.
Today, my main
focus is going to be
on the hilt. To get this hilt
going, what I'm going to need
to do is tack the guard and
quillon to the blade itself
in order to start building
the basket around that.
I'm very happy with
my progress so far.
I feel like I have
a real good shot.
Hopefully it holds up to
whatever test they throw at me.
Everything looks great,
but I've got one final touch
that I want to do to my weapon.
I use a little purple, a little
gold, and a little silver,
and I really brighten up the
image of the Purple Heart.
She is a beautiful,
beautiful sword.
What can I test it on?
I want to be the
first person to hack
something up with this thing.
It just screams, go
out and swing me.
But I'm not putting my blade
through a rigorous test here.
I'm just seeing if
the edge is good.
So I set up some swim noodles.
That'll do.
All right, bladesmiths.
Captain Mad Jack Churchill may
have been mad enough to take
a backsword into modern combat.
But what I want to know is,
are your swords mad enough
if called upon to kill?
To that end, I will
deliver some killing
blows to this ballistics dummy.
Billy, you are first.
You ready for this?
I came here to watch you
kill and chew bubblegum,
and I'm out of bubblegum.
All right.
Let's do this.
[heavy metal music]
All right, Billy.
First up, I really like the
way the Damascus spatter
shows in your sword.
Now, your handle--
it's comfortable.
There are no hot spots.
Every cut you do with this blade
is sharp enough to cut deeply.
Overall, your weapon will kill.
Thank you very much.
All right, Robert.
Your turn, sir.
Are you ready?
- I'm ready.
Let's do this.
[suspenseful music]
I will not be denied.
All right, Robert.
Let's talk about
your backsword here.
The tip-- very pointy, thrust
in easily, cuts on the way out.
Your handle here-- it's loose.
It's really wiggling in my hand.
But overall, sir, your
backsword will kill.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the strength test.
Today, I'm going to
take your swords,
and I'm a clear a path
through this big block of ice.
And I don't really care what
your swords do to the ice.
I want to see what the
ice does to your swords.
Billy, you look
ready to be first.
Jay, I was born ready.
There we go.
The ice block is brutal.
It can chip the edge of a blade.
It can break a blade.
I'm a little nervous
going into this.
Nothing left to it but
to it but to do it.
[heavy metal music]
Billy, nice job.
Thank you.
I'm sure you could see when I
striking that, the blade flexed
all over the place and
came right back to where
it was in the beginning.
Everything is tight.
Nice job.
Thank you very much.
Robert, how you feeling?
- I'm ready.
- Good.
I'm ready too.
Let's do it.
[suspenseful music]
I'd be lying if I said
I'm not nervous right now.
A sword isn't made to
hit a block of ice.
When two hard things hit
each other like that,
something's got to give.
Hopefully, the ice gives
more than my sword gives.
[heavy metal music]
Oh, no.
I really don't know
what to think right now.
This right here
is where it hurts.
It feels like something pulled.
Watching Jay scream
out in pain like that,
I feel that pain as well.
It's kind of catching
me a little bit back here.
I hate that
something that I did
caused pain to another person.
Plus, it's loose.
I see Jay stepping
off the testing floor.
I'm pretty sure this is it.
This is it for me.
Bladesmiths, in any one
of our finale competitions,
the way that you
design those blades
to perform in our
challenges is always
taken into consideration.
And Robert,
unfortunately, your weapon
has hurt our user so
severely that we had to send
him to the emergency room.
Your weapon has
been given a vote
of no confidence and cannot
move forward in testing.
And for that reason,
I have to ask
you to please leave the forge.
First and
foremost, I hope that
Jay doesn't suffer any long-term
effects of this injury.
I took my time making
sure that everything
was safe on this blade.
So to find out that I
missed something, that's
kind of devastating, you know?
I know that I'm able to
compete with some of the best
bladesmiths here in the world.
I know that this is my place.
This is my calling in life.
I'm certainly not going to stop.
I'm going to keep
pushing forward.
I'm going to get
better at what I do.
This is just another rung
on the ladder to success.
Billy, your blade is
sharp, deadly, and strong,
and you are the Forge
of Fire Champion.
And that is a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job, brother.
Woo!
I'm the Forged in Fire Champion.
This is awesome.
This has been an
amazing experience,
and I'm very blessed and honored
to have been a part of it.
[heavy metal music]